Thanks for telling us about the
importance of proper dessert selection.
So let's choose our desserts now.
The earliest platform version that
our Apple support is Gingerbread.
At the current time, choosing
Gingerbread means we can cover over 99%
of the devices active
on Google Playstore.
It's also the cutoff for using Google
Play services for things like maps and
location and
the Android support library.
The support library package offers an
implementation of ui features that were
added in later releases of Android but
now can be used on older
versions of the platform.
So it's really useful.
Notice how we picked the latest
version of Gingerbread with API level
10 because it contains additional bug
fixes that API level 9 doesn't have.
The we can go ahead and click Next.
We're going to choose the template,
Blank Activity with Fragment.
For background context and
activity serves as the present layer for
our UI, and a fragment represents
a behavior or portion of the screen.
And now we have an option to modify
the names of the files that will be
auto-generated from the wizard.
The name of our activity
is MainActivity, and
the layout will come from activity_main,
which is an XML file.
In a similar fashion, the fragments
layout will come from fragment_main,
which is also an XML file.
I'm going to do a small change for
the name of the menu file to be called
main.xml because on a older version of
Android's tu, that was the default name.
Then we go ahead and hit Finish.
And now you should have a newly
created sunshine app with the files on
the left here.
By default, you may see
the Android view of the files,
which is a flattened version
of the project structure,
and it highlights the key Android
source files that you'll need to edit.
In this course, though, we're going to
be using the project view because that's
what we had in the older
version of Android Studio.
You can choose any view that you prefer,
though.
Make sure you wait for
the gradle build to finish.
If you have any errors, you can check
the guide and instructor notes below.
As a tip,
you can check the build.gradle file,
which is located under the App folder.
You want to make sure that
the compileSdkVersion and
the targetSdkVersion are both pointing
at the latest stable version of
the platform.
In this case, it's 21 for
the Android 5.0 Lollipop release.
Once it's done building, we can add a
custom app icon that's more fitting for
our weather app.
Right-click on the App folder and
click New Image Asset.
You can choose from any of
the clip art options or
you can use the one that we
provide in the download below.
Then, use a placeholder icon we
provide in a download below.
Now this will show up in
the All Apps screen, so
that clicking on this app
icon will launch our app.
It will also show up in the overview
space if sunshine is one of
your most recent tasks.
The other place you might see this app
icon is in the action bar of our app.
In certain videos of this course that
were filmed earlier on Kit Kat by
default the action bar
shows the app icon.
With material design on Lollipop and
later, the app icon doesn't show up
by default anymore, so
don't worry if you don't see it.
It's fine, and
we're going to be styling the action
bar later in lesson five, anyways.